this tennis academy on the outskirts of
Brie a sleepy city in rural Belgium one
of the most unlikely comebacks in
sporting history is taking shape
Kim cloisters used to be world number
one a four-time Grand Slam champion now
what she's 36 a mother of three and
about to return to top-level tennis for
the first time in seven years in her
first TV interview since announcing her
comeback
I asked Kleist is about the venture
she's calling her third career how do
you feel out on court compared to say
when you're in your late teens early
twenties it's hard to compare to how I
felt when I was 21 years old I was I'm
sure I was a lot quicker I was a lot
faster my eyesight was better my
reactions were quicker but I do feel
like I can still yeah her best crisis
was a fierce rival of Serena Williams
the US Open in 2009 she beat the
American in the semi-final lifting the
trophy holding daughter jarda in her
other arm earlier this month
Williams too won her first tournament as
a mother while Roger Federer continues
to compete aged 38
do you look at the likes of Serena
Williams and Venus Williams and more
Federer playing in sort of their mid to
late thirties and Beyond and think you
know what tennis may be an older
person's sport right now um yeah I mean
it looks like it is I mean I think you
know over the years I think Venus to me
has been someone who have really looked
up to and just seeing what serena has
done in the last year's you know she she
had her baby and has been incredible as
well it's there for a mom of three kids
and I know that's the the major role in
your life is there any guilt that you
have for coming back I think you lose a
little bit of the guilt as your kids get
older the more kids you have
I remember when Jada was little and I
had to go to practice and and you know
she would be standing inside of our
house and I would come here and practice
you know for my tournaments and then she
would be crying at the at the glass
backdoor and and and I would feel so
guilty and I would think like what am i
doing
it's one of the most likeable players in
tennis Cloisters will be warmly welcomed
back but she'll have to get used to this
level of scrutiny wants more a price
she'll happily pay to success Martha
Kellner Sky News three